I want to talk about the best open world
games this year because when I first
thought a segment or like a few of us
were brainstorming we thought there were
more than there actually were I feel
like there's always at least like 10
open world games every year but they're
actually weren't a ton this year and I
think like between watchdogs to
releasing very recently and Final
Fantasy 15 just releasing today it's
kind of a good time to touch on it I
want to talk about her favorites what do
we think the best was I think we all
kind of picked one out to mainly talked
about but i'll touch on all of them
b.braun yeah which one of which one of
you thinking of the best died sorry just
to clarify I mean in like a traditional
sandbox open world as opposed to Dark
Souls 3 which you have to like fast
travel at certain points and there's
like certain gates that you can't get
through for a while and it's very
segmented i'm talking like sandbox games
like yeah it's it's very difficult for
me to choose for me it comes down to no
man's sky watchdogs to or Final Fantasy
15 all for very different reasons which
so high it's so hard to say the best I
will say my favorite right now having
played watchdogs to and Final Fantasy 15
recently between those two is Final
Fantasy 15 both games offer a lot of
discovery like if you spend your time
really digging around you'll find things
that are really surprising and
entertaining in some cases but really
for me I think it's yeah it's 15 just
because of the the scale of progression
like you I'm 65 hours in and I can still
see another 10 or 15 hours worth of
things that I want to find and explore
and unlike something like no man's sky
you know I know what I'm working towards
in 15 I love no man's sky for its
spectacle and and a few other reasons
but at the end of the day after I met
Atlas I was kind of like well I've got
better things to do to myself yeah and
we will get into Final Fantasy 15 way
more later in this show today but I do
think it's interesting because i think
it's i make it known i've never played a
final fantasy game before and i just
bought this last night i'm going to be
playing tonight it's weird that the
allure of a final fantasy is that it's a
pure open-world now as opposed like the
characters in the story line which you
said were serviceable and again that's a
critique is too much until we get into
the reviewer section later but it is odd
that i'm getting into a final fantasy
because of its like you know gorgeous
sprawling pure open-world sandbox yeah I
mean but that's you know that is sort of
the flavor of the month right or the
generation as it work i mean we saw a
metal gear solid go open world final
fantasy is following and you know a lot
of games are sort of shifting how they
they handle their traditions and putting
it in a modern package and so I can I
think I can relate to how that is
interesting even as a final fantasy fan
that has me stoke so I can see for
someone who has never played the series
before how that would tip them over and
to bind the game I guess yeah just
seeing it from a distance it looks
gorgeous which isn't always like the
biggest selling point obviously but it
does seem like there's enough to like
keep you pulling you from region to
region these like late game Dungeons and
missions and like bosses and legendary
weapons sound like they'd be worth
exploring for of the three that you
mentioned Peter do you think um if you
were to pick one to be the most
repetitive cuz that's like one of my
biggest burnouts it's like oh I can I've
been kind of doing this it's no man's
sky yeah easily yeah yeah I mean
watchdogs to is set in a city you know
San Francisco that has a lot of natural
variety and that game represents it very
well you have a lot of different
activities you can involve yourself in
and 15 is kind of the same way really
combat and discovery are the two main
things but yeah for no man's sky it was
so repetitive to have to constantly you
know grind for resources and ultimately
to take the next step time and time
again and just repeat that cycle and
keep it going like that that was super
repetitive for me yeah that was me last
night until very very late just like
wait and that I feel like that can get
deceiving to with some like no man's sky
where you still have those cool but like
spectacle moments like occasionally like
when you do find that cool planet or
like that like enjoyable and like like
tasteful animal to look at and it's just
like hideous freak of nature that you
just like come on I just this thing
something straight up like the early
drawing boards of the Last Guardian that
they thought you might be like wandering
on that world with supposed to Treecko
now I think what I mean I've showed you
guys at that one animals are
what animal that I showed you guys
that's like got these wings and it's
just huge like what is that like come on
I can't wait for the gift of this that's
just me got a preview monitor here and
it's just me uh yeah for me I suppose
division was one of my pics simply just
for that tone and that aesthetic of that
city was super like all right I would
say your original right like you know
you think about like a GTA or like watch
dogs like there's such a light
heartedness where it's just you know
those moments moments of just like some
crazy event happening but this game
division was like that's messed up this
one makes me think when I see someone
innocent civilian just getting civilian
just getting like beat the hell up if I
can't save them in time they die like
you there's a guilt and there's just
like a it's scary it's a scary game and
that was like very different for like of
the lineup I feel like for this yeah we
talked about a few times in the lobby
between like being like PT our servers
and just through actually recent
released the survival mode now I think
I've said this a lot but this is one
game I only put two hours into back in
March when it released and I've been
wanting to play it ever since because
from what I played it was the world that
was drawing me in again we've talked
about before is just deja vu but now
that survival modes out a lot of people
are saying again this world makes more
sense now as an open world because it's
a very risk reward do I want to spend a
lot of time here even though the
blizzards gonna eventually freeze me to
death if I don't get to a fuel drum I
need food any water I'm not gonna be
able a manned kill these harder enemies
if I'm too thirsty I need better gear do
I want to venture off the beaten path
even though I know this way safe you
know I I really I key again i keep
saying it but once i finish all the
other games like the current games i
want to get back to the division that
looks like one of mine I don't know that
it's the best I don't know it's my
favorite because I've only put two hours
into it but it's the most alluring to me
in terms of its aesthetic and its
overall world design yeah I think I
don't know when you could date it back
for open world games but it for me I
member fallout 4 having that impact
would like to survive a mode like the
game felt natural and at its core and I
feel like I think Far Far Cry primal did
that I never gone into that version but
division seems like a perfect place to
have
that I like you I mean why else is there
I guess you have perks associated with
like water bottles and soda cans and
division but it's night it's nice to
like know that like that's actually
something that you are looking for like
heavily there they're just like you know
goodies to sprinkle in yeah you did just
talk about Far Cry primal and that's
actually one that I'm not surprised we
haven't talked about a lot it's just
like it's the Far Cry 3 far cry 4 to to
some extent formula implanted on the
other stone age and but when I reviewed
it and i when i played it i actually
really like that game i was really
impressed that Ubisoft didn't kind of
eventually just give you like this
machine gun rock thrower or the sling
this electric spear anything they too
need Statham pretty grounded aside from
like the mystical elements but it stayed
ground in this world and you just
mentioned that they released that update
afterward that added the like a survival
mode I did play a little bit of it and I
again like you said with fallout 4 and
even with the division I think that's
the way to play this game when you know
like in the base game when night fell
and when like the Sun went down that's
when a lot of the Predators will come
out fires were good for warding off like
wolves and whatnot but now apparently
you know there's cold to maintain which
is in the first game or the base game as
well but it just became way more
dangerous in survival mode which is what
I liked about the base game did you did
you guys even play a lot of Far Cry
primal yeah you gotta play good amount
and you know it just like many games I
think can fall victim to that you just
get a too overpowered and I think
survival works so well for open world is
giving you that that that strong
incentive to make that weapon to go like
to be on the cusp of dying you know and
I think Parker is a perfect example of
like making a spear-like gets Legree old
bow and arrow is the first thing you
make like that's pretty much survival
like it fits well there and you know I
just realized even know man sky did that
with this new update I haven't tried it
yet though but yeah it's just
interesting it's just like making
incentive and making you feel
uncomfortable I think is something
appealing and you know then to look back
50 hours in like dang I I got out of
that rut like I don't know it's more
empowering yeah it is weird because
again I think the game was pretty
forgettable against that far cry formula
that we've kind of come to know and
maybe get sick of
um but looking back it is actually one
of my like favorite open world
experiences this year although i haven't
played final fantasy yet but to continue
talking about ubisoft which now that I
say it out loud they had three open most
of the games on this list are you be
soft titles yeah obviously they have
different Studios all over the world but
watch dogs too we kind of touched on
living here in San Francisco I think was
the main allure of that game before I
came out I did not like the first watch
dogs some of the problems I had with the
first watchdogs carried over to this one
I played about four or five hours of
watchdogs to PE reviewed it but I still
felt like it was kind of lifeless I know
it's tough to have enough people in a
city in a game to make it feel like it's
really vibrant kind of just like
pulsating like I wanted to and I was
exploring San Francisco just to see some
of the sites the tourist attractions uh
see if you could find like our office or
my neighborhood neither of which won the
game but you reviewed it what like what
do you think about the world itself as
it functions like as an open-world game
you're a high percent correct like
lifeless is a adjective that applies I
think to a degree right like there are
not that many people on the street there
is not that many cars on the road
there's enough to kind of give you those
variables to at least consider but yeah
it doesn't feel like San Francisco in
that respect but the open world I think
benefited from again what I was saying
earlier like the variety that exists
within it the visual variety the terrain
variety and the terrain being urban and
natural I thought there was a very very
good mix of those two so in terms of the
open-world being alive I don't know that
that was necessarily the case but I felt
a live in that open world oh [ __ ] qty my
fella ya know Rob you live dude Richard
Lee our cameraman is trying not to laugh
at that sick sick comment no I should be
fired for this I'm gonna buy that game
now did you put that you play a lot of
watchdogs to rob I didn't item played
any oak and fortunately um yeah it's
just I think this time around you know
this year as they say is like has been
just an influx of really awesome
shooters it's kind of been where my mind
I think has
like I feel like I've just been burning
exhausted over the last few years of
open world games worse like just you
know even when I came out like i was
playing dayz like the first year i've
ever started gamespot like those those
games i can't do anymore because they
just kill me like oh man it's 4am and I
haven't seen [ __ ] like I I mean that's
your extreme game but like I'm a little
afraid to play wash dogs too just
because I I'm afraid of the moment we're
like I see that really funny I keep
hearing with this gameplay moment where
you walk around it's like someone
freaking out and beating up a car yeah
but I've heard that from many people so
I'm wondering when like hmm when is that
going to be the third time or fourth
time that I've just kind of experienced
that uh you know I had to say like you
know you compare that to like the five
years for GTA like that shows like I
still tuned into that game once while
and I'm like oh I don't think I've ever
heard that yeah and that is weary it's
just like I it's it's super hard to top
that well the world I will say the one
thing that watch dogs to offers is a
very easy way to get strangers either
near or far to like share a piece of
themselves with you by stealing that
piece from him right by reading their
text messages or listening in on their
phone calls and there are some funny
anecdotes in there like it's not to the
same caliber of where you get in GTA
because you're not it's not an organic
experience it is something you have to
like trigger right and again it is just
something very quick and then it's gone
but i will say that in its defense there
is a lot of character buried within that
world you have to go just a little bit
farther to get to it and that's where
the first one fell short right like you
had those text messages or like those
just I no bios right but they were like
three words or [ __ ] for words like who
cares like what is that a value but yeah
when I hear that that's pretty cool like
yeah we haven't been a story sorry yeah
we haven't been any crazy dumb tangents
yet today so here's mine have you seen
the movie bedazzled way back in the day
is it a documentary about adding
gemstone no no it's a friend Frasier
Frasier and Jennifer my fifth no sorry
Elizabeth Hurley it's it really your
fifth favorite know
it's a one of this is useless and almost
a non sequitur but at the beginning of
that movie I forget how it fits into the
theme of the movie but they do that they
showed this like bio of someone hovering
above them hmm I don't even know how it
fits in the rest of the movie now that I
think out loud but when i first played
the first watch dogs i thought a brandon
fraiser and Elizabeth Hurley and
bedazzle anyway the last one I wanted to
talk about was DLC Witcher 3 blood and
wine oh it sure will bring it up because
it's an entirely new area that you
explore it's like it's a new region it's
kind of like it this French like
Toussaint and it's you know like French
dialect kind of spoken there um you put
some time into this oh and I was on a
roll yeah what she's what oh oh she's
talking Oh Mary through both bedazzled
yeah oh gee yeah let's VAM oh there's go
ahead my even in San Francisco so watch
dogs too and a lot of segues this is
chris burrman ubisoft you're ripping off
bedazzle no I'm just kidding here's a
gears for those listening Mary just
threw up the intracoastal talking about
yeah this one guy double dips this
versus X it'd be a lot of watchdogs to
you by there is Brendan Fraser's
lovesick X da go on walking down market
street he's desperate oblivious eager to
please this is blowing nose holy [ __ ] I
kind of the when I first started talking
about like this is the worst tangent
ever but now I actually like seems like
I had a plan the whole time I think you
just unearthed the secret to walk jog
burn areas they didn't have the guts to
just completely rip it off so they've
set the first one Chicago like we'll get
to san francisco in the sequel anyway
doormat he's a dork all right bites his
toenails so tucson in the witcher 3
blood and whines entirely new like open
world segment it's just like french
speaking kind of more stable environment
than the base game the base games world
was kind of you know in the middle of a
civil war Rob blood and wines you play
yeah yeah I really liked it a lot and I
was like on a role playing that game and
then how do you know we go through a lot
of games here so you have to like put
things down but yeah in that that felt
like Witcher 3 point 5 it just
felt like a whole it I think it was
probably like the best deals in man well
my favorites was like when the best deal
sees I think of the year just because
like there was just so much going on and
that is a living breathing world for the
most part just for the amount of quests
and characters you are constantly
meeting you know it's it's a game we're
like you can't do it all uh and that
says a lot means i think you know you
say the same for like fallout as well
but just like the change of a tone and
heart for witcher you know yeah you had
a civil war with like to say i'm not
genocide but like tons of casualties in
a war like in the mud like dead and
here's really like chirpy uh frenchtown
like sunsets and just gorgeous like
locales like it was a cool way to close
out that game CD Projekt RED is as
they've proven time and time again are
really good at telling these open world
stories that these things you just
stumble upon but also these things that
tie different regions of the open world
together and kind of give you a reason
to explore beyond just like new weapons
or gear just actually uncovering these
really well-written tangential stories i
didn't get to play much blood and wine
this year unfortunately i played hearts
of stone last year which is a really
good expansion that was more linear
you're going to places within the
original based games world and now that
blood and wine is out i think the
witcher 3 is even more of a you know
high bar for open world games and i had
a cool time with hearts of smokes i
actually didn't get a chance to play
when it came out so what you could do is
actually play them both at the same time
i don't think i've ever done this with
dlc before i guess yeah i can't remember
if I have but anyways going back and
forth between worlds like you know in
hearthstone you you know spoiler you get
like a scar from guy on your face and he
says I won't remove it remove it until
you do something so I'm going around
like to saw with a scar in my face like
I don't think people react to it but
like it was just kind of interesting to
be like man I I should probably the scar
off my face like just multitasking I
don't know I just felt cool to like go
back and forth between like as you said
like really awesome well-rounded stories
it was just fun to like have that
freedom yeah I remember how you get that
scar removed there's like a laser
surgeon in the swamp or something what's
that the man of glass it was a joke but
I forget how you can score
yeah the that dude gone Toro dim the guy
that a hell of a villain did you come
back in blood and wine or is that a
spoiler or do you even know there's this
there was this really cool like arch
character that they introduced in a
heart of stone that I thought they were
laying the groundwork for later stories
I don't know if anybody in the chat
knows if you played bloodwine let me
know if gon throw dem is back but anyway
those were the you know the major
open-world games like most of which were
ubisoft titles and some of which may
have ripped off a 90's movie or two
agreed yeah so yeah now that I have
Final Fantasy 15 I'm gonna try to get
into that tonight and I will have played
most of these games this year but anyway
let us know if we missed any that you
want us to mention let us know what your
favorites are and what next movie
Ubisoft should rip off
[Music]